[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
everybody's having a great week and are
enjoying the shiny conference thank you
so much to the Absalon team for putting
on this amazing conference and for
asking for the data science Hangout to
be a part of that it's really cool to be
included in the conference if somebody
is here from the hangout and doesn't
know what I'm talking about with the
shiny conference
can we share the link in the chat so
they know how to join in too
um but I know we have quite a few people
here joining the data science hangout
for the very first time so thank you all
so much for joining us
I'm Rachel Dempsey and I lead our Pro
community at posit so we Host this data
science hangout every Thursday at the
same time same place
so what is it what's going on here this
is our open space to chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data across
different Industries and so every week
we feature a different data science
leader as my co-host to help lead our
discussion and answer questions from you
all
there's no presentations or slides just
all conversation with everybody we're
all dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everyone and so we
always love to hear from everybody no
matter your level of experience or area
of work
this is a bit different than the hop-in
platform that you're in for the the
shiny conference so I just want to make
people aware of that to be a bit careful
with unmuting and those things that come
with zoom
we'll be watching out for it too but
just wanted to to make that clear it is
totally totally okay to just listen in
here
um but there's also three ways that you
can jump in so you can ask questions or
provide your own perspective on certain
topics
by raising your hand here on Zoom
if you're not familiar with zoom it's in
the bar below where it says reactions if
you click on that you can raise your
hand
but you can also put questions in the
zoom chat and if you want just put a
little star next to it if you don't want
to jump in and read it yourself I'll
know that maybe you're in a coffee shop
or something and you want me to read it
and then lastly we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and our team here a posit
we'll share that into the chat in just a
second uh we'll keep posting it in there
so that people can find it as well it's
great to see all the messages in the
chat
we do share the recordings of each
session to the posit YouTube and our
data science hangout site so you can
always go back and re-watch or share
with a friend
but with all of that thank you so much
for joining it's so amazing to see this
fig group that we have here today and
thank you so much David for joining us
as our featured leader David granjon is
a senior full stack shiny developer at
Novartis and the founder and maintainer
of the open source R interface
organization where he develops shiny
extensions like BS for Dash and shiny
mobile
we also have Bo Wang senior expert data
science at Novartis who's also joining
us in the audience today we'll be
helping with any questions that come up
on there
data monitoring committees at Novartis
as well so let me bring you both your uh
to introduce yourselves as well David
I'd love to have you introduce yourself
and maybe share a little bit about your
role and also something you like to do
outside of work
hi everyone thanks for having me
um
I was one in France 32 years ago and
married I have one wonderful daughter a
wonderful wife
um I'm yeah doing uh data science that
provides since lawyers my background is
about Applied Mathematics
um so I have like quite a
sort of Swiss knife background where I
can do physics I can do mathematics
chemistry a lot of different things and
also background in web development
um so when I learned web development I
learned HTML CSS PHP and also databases
on the on the side
um
and I'm super glad I was able to attend
the keynote before from Colleen because
I like spot a lot as well
I hate running
but I like cycling a lot I'm probably
for the same reasons as Colleen so yeah
at some point no matter what spot you
are doing if it's
making you better feeling you better
having new IDs yeah taking some insight
of what you are doing
that's just what do you have to do
we did have a really fun picture of
David with his like goggles on like
getting ready to go out for a bike ride
that we might have to go up with the
recording too
thank you again David Bo so nice to have
you here too be great to have you
introduce yourself as well I'm gonna
jump in
thank you thank you for having me
um first of all I love running and I
hate biking I didn't know about you w
that you didn't like running
maybe we can team up as a relay team in
the triathloners or something I hated
biking when I tried it
um anyway so my name is Bo I work on the
same team as David and Novartis we are
data scientists who
um build tools pipelines to support our
clinical
statisticians and other data science
functions
I my background is in biostatistics
but I since uh since I started working
in the in the Pharma industry I've been
working on
um more on the tool development
um almost like software development side
than actual travel analysis although I
have been
um
working on supporting data monitoring
committees as Rachel mentioned before
and there seemed to be a bit of interest
in that on that topic in previous
meetings so that's why I'm here
um
last set of work that like I said I like
running I like traveling I'm actually
right now in Memphis Tennessee even
though I'm normally based in Boston
um I do not have a wife or a daughter
I do have a dog who I treat is my
daughter
she's at my foot napping
and that's pretty much it glad to be
here thank you thank you so much for for
joining us and just a quick reminder to
everybody if you're not talking if you
want to just
um if you want to just mute yourself
it'll be really helpful
too okay cool thank you so much so I get
the uh pleasure of being able to ask
some of the first questions as we wait
for questions to come in but if anybody
did just join us after the initial
introductions I wanted to let you know
that you can ask questions a few
different ways so you can put questions
into the zoom chat you can also raise
your hand on on zoom and I'll call you
in when we also have a slido link which
we'll share again where you can ask
questions anonymously too
um but something I was really excited to
to start off with asking is
David I know you think a lot about
building great user interfaces and I was
curious to hear tips you have for all of
us and communicating with the business
through data visualizations
yeah sure so from I think we studied a
big project last year which is around
probably a few of success
and then for this project we really
thought about another way to start our
senior projects especially you know from
the user interface perspective
so I would say
when I joined Novartis at the beginning
most of the time we were you know
rushing into code we developed the
interface the app and then we showed the
app to the end user and then they are
not happy with the result
um we completely changed the process and
with this project we basically start
with wireframing so we had we met with
the user we draw the user requirements
we discussed together for one week two
weeks and then we present some mock-ups
some wire framing so you could basically
either use a paper and a pen or you can
use most sophisticated tools
um I would say it's a bit of pity but
most of the good wireframing tool you
had to pay we are using balsamic
Novelties
you may use it you may not pretend if
you know and then based on that we spend
around I would say one month before we
can come to an agreement and then we can
start to to code
so we really developed the application
for the end user let's just from our
perspective you know so it really
satisfies what they want
awesome thank you I'm starting to see a
lot of the questions coming in the chat
and thanks so much to the positive team
for helping me organize these um but
Libby I see you asked a question do you
want to jump in
yeah I was just wondering if we could
get an overview of some of the big
projects that you've been working on at
Novartis I know that Novartis is a
Pharma company and that it's really big
but being a person outside of the Pharma
Universe I sometimes don't know what you
guys are working on
uh you want to start on this one though
and then I will take next
sure
um so two of the bigger projects I've
been working on one I've been working on
for a couple of years
um basically when a clinical trial is
being conducted there are a lot of data
analysis
um on the patient data that we collect
from the enrollees
um and
for later stage for later that there are
like earlier faces trials in a small
amount of patients with lower Doses and
then once the safety established you
move on to later phases with larger
number of patients and higher doses for
efficacy announcements for example but
the safety efficient safety is always
monitored through all the phases
um and for later stage studies
the sponsor in Pharma lingo the sponsor
is a pharmaceutical company that pays
for the clinical trial anyone inside the
sponsor company are not supposed to know
the
actual treatment of the patients given
if the if the study is a randomized
control trial
so we need to hire external external
Partners excuse me foreign excuse me
thank you
uh we need to hire we as sponsors have
to hire
um external experts to be unblinded to
the actual treatment code and review
safety data to make sure that all the
patients in the ongoing trial are still
safe
um so one of the big projects I've been
working on in the past couple years is
um writing
um and managing an app a shiny app that
has a JavaScript backend
to display some of the safety data in
the more user-friendly way than say 200
pages of pH of PDF because the DMC
members tend to be very highly regarded
very expensive their time is very
expensive experts in their field so they
have very limited time that they can
give us to review the data so having an
app
um as a supplementary tool
AIDS their review of the data with the
limited time that they have
thank you to you
yeah since I joined Novelties I've been
very lucky regarding all the projects I
received uh surprisingly at the
beginning uh like during my first months
I was given a project not about clinical
data but for human resources data
because you you have to imagine you know
now that is it's
like hundred thousand people working and
then you have many departments it's not
only clinical but it's on it's also
sales human resources and many other
things and basically we had to develop a
tool to better manage the time people
spend on projects
and these two was basically first
developed with shiny with a lot of
databases around uh just to like to that
data assistance
and then later the tool was improved
using other Technologies like react but
in the end yeah it shows you know how
you can integrate shining the the whole
ecosystem
and that was a great project
um then uh I joined like the the
probability of success initiative
um which was really rewarding project
because we really
had a checklist and tried to respect all
possible best practices which was this
checklist was based on the mistake we
made we made on all the other projects
and then yeah we studied with the wire
framing then we had like a strong CI CD
setup so yeah I'm responsible of the
ticd setup of the team so making sure we
have so we are using gitlab so we have
Runners with proper installations then
the balances everything
so if you want to do like headless
testing for your training apps you make
sure you got the proper installation and
yeah so sitting a good Runners uh and
yeah how to to manage the readies you
know the prediction release so this
afternoon we had during the conference
we had the production release of us the
1.0.0 the first one which is uh like one
year of work so that's quite a big
achievement
um and also I've been involved so POS is
clinical data right it's really to I
didn't really get the background but you
know when you work in Pharma Pharma
companies they invest billions into
making a treatment it's not just like
tensiles and it's really billions so we
need to make sure what you are going to
do is successful at some point so you
need to know to analyze the markets and
everything
um and this property of success tools
provide like your data driven solution
to have an improved diagnosis
for photography of success
um and yeah finally I've been involved
in the
in migration so it's more like in the
server infrastructure to migrate from
Chinese server Pro to our studio connect
so initially yeah we had changed our Pro
and now we have our steel connect so I
had to supervise this migration so
essentially talking about sales on
applications and make sure you know this
application work correctly unless you
connect the position connect now
uh so that was quite challenging because
um
all apps were not necessarily following
all the best practices you know
essentially around the package
dependencies so sometimes you are not
able to find you know where a package is
coming from
yeah and the application was just not
working anymore so we we did a lot of
work around RL to set up reproducible
environments or many projects
which has a learning curve
but uh yeah we we are making progress
right
yeah we're also tracking usage and our
steel connect so using the the API
getting the the data from the server to
see you know how people are using the
applications and stuff like that so
that's very not only people data that's
all data
awesome
cool to use to hear using that that API
too to get those Advanced uh usage
metrics I'm seeing a ton of questions
coming in here too and I wanted to make
sure
um get to the ones from the chat too and
so sep I see you had asked a question
um around validation do you want to jump
in and ask that sure thanks guys for
jumping in and sharing your stories I
know Beau already kind of answered it
but a validation is usually especially
in kind of regulated Industries is a is
a arduous uh task generally and so I was
kind of really interested to see is that
something that you guys have built that
required validation to be
undertaken you know sometimes people
have alternatives to that so if you
could speak to that other guest a little
bit more Bo or David that'd be great
yes I think arduous is the right word
for to describe the whole process as I
discovered in the past couple years
um I came from my um previous experience
in my
um work throughout my career my graduate
school career I had never encountered
the issue of having to validate a piece
of software or a piece of application
um
not in the like a code review and
testing
sense but in the process documentation
sense so it was definitely a learning
curve and
um we have had a few iterations of
processes that are based on software
validation
when I say software you can think of
rstudio the shiny server or the RS
connect as a piece of software that we
have existing
processes written authored by it to
support
but apparently those processes are a
little there's a little there's a little
too much overhead for a shiny
application so in the past I would say a
year and a half two years we've been
working
um with our QA colleagues our it
colleagues
and
our colleague who are managing our
deployment system or analytical system
to
kind of
um communicate both ways what does
quality mean for our QA colleagues what
does equality mean for it what does
quality mean for business and try to
a region understanding of how much
testing how much documentation is needed
it's still an ongoing process we've had
a few pilot projects deploy deploying
apps for for use in DMC but
um
there are like exceptions for certain
studies that does not apply to other
studies so the solution for certain
issues don't really translate to
long-term solutions that you can write
in the in the process in like a business
process on how to validate a shiny
application so that's the part that
we're still trying to figure out as we
incorporate more different types of
studies
in the program
thanks so much
thank you
Travis I see you had a question as well
and I forgot to say if I know there's a
lot of people who are here for the first
time so if when you jump in and ask your
question if you want to introduce
yourself that would be awesome too
yeah and I would love to know where you
are outside right now yeah what's um
still San Diego
um it's nice here I saw a few of you
here in SoCal I'm Travis Gerke I'm also
in the department of Sierra space
um and I'm a regular jokester here on
the on the hangout in the chat usually
um yeah this is awesome I did have a
question we we also moved away from 800
page PDFs to
um you know more HTML based products but
it's been a game changer for our safety
monitoring boards they really like it um
but we're not as fancy as you I'm we're
doing more reactable kind of static HTML
documents partly because of the
challenge which you just discussed
around validation of um shiny servers so
I'm glad to Seth asked that question but
I do one one thing that's a gap for us
um the feedback that we get from the
monitors
um is still this kind of clunky maybe
they'll write a long email or give us
Excel sheets or other things back
um are you thinking about or have you
gotten any feedback from users writing
their app which is seems like a good
opportunity in the shiny environment
um trying to understand
your question are you asking if we have
got positive feedback on the format of
the shiny application from the monitors
no actually the data points themselves
um so a lot of times they'll look at a
patient profile they go ah the slab
value are you sure this is right or
um you know just the usual kinds of
sometimes it's even data quality
questions which are valid because the
the monitors are often content matter
experts medical experts and they see
things that we as data scientists don't
um yeah it would be very convenient if
while they're looking at your app going
through the what was previously 900
pages of PDFs if they could say like
highlight this and kind of submit right
through the app and you could kind of
get feedback in that format rather than
more oh I see methods
oh I see
um no we haven't Incorporated that
um in our app to accept feedback
directly in the app from the DMC members
um in fact the feedback we've received
are mostly not directly from DMC members
even in the email chain
um because for pivotal studies for later
phase studies we hire an external cro to
interact with the DMC members directly
and we normally just get feedback from
them because we're not invited to the
meetings because we can't risk um
unblinding even though the developers
are not technically part of the trial
team but we are still part of Nevada's
business so
um there are a few that's that's one of
the things that's been it's part of my
learning curve also how many
um and like silos are intended
in the process of clinical data review
just to make sure
data is secure
um
but I I'm sure David might have
something to say about
um building the function of feedback
into the app interface to make it more
user-friendly
yeah that's great from David yeah
because um I I guess I asked my question
from I'm in the cro side so um that that
feedback loop is something we're in and
you're on the sponsor side so you're
right um interesting Silo that we um you
know must adhere to I suppose
any other thoughts David
yeah sorry a primary Beast uh like the
last part of trevi's question
um about the user feedback right
[Music]
the try followed correctly
it was um it was about when when you all
are giving these reports of um you know
like patient profiles let's say so long
what was previously long 900 page
listings in PDF form
um now you're doing interactive probably
kind of more elegant uh web-facing
applications for viewing these
um for us on the cro side which Bo
hopefully just described as something
you all don't have to deal with we have
to receive feedback from the monitor
um and you know safety committees
committees it'd be convenient if the
shiny app uh allowed them to do so
directly in a way that links it to the
data they were actually viewing at the
time they gave feedback
um because we we lose a lot of context
sometimes when they try to tell us
um you know oh we looked at this patient
profile in patient 001
has an abnormal lab value and we're kind
of like going back through the data
going wait what
um you know in a shiny app seems like an
opportune way to make that easier
it is indeed uh but I remember one
project where uh it was for like
specific people team and then uh we had
like a kind of surprising uh reaction
you know from the from the end user
because they were actually not really
convinced about the shenya they would
actually prefer using the the PDF the
table listing you know this threatening
things
um just because yeah there were like
many options in the
like the safety Explorer widgets stuff
like that um too many options they
didn't know where to click
um yeah that wasn't clear uh in some
situation they would end up with data
they don't really know uh yeah what what
it means so
um yeah
oh sorry
it depends if you are already familiar
with this kind of tools you know if you
are familiar with web application or not
I would say
that's such a good point we've gotten
that feedback before too we built
something really elegant and then
someone says Ah but can't you just give
me 900 pages in paper
I feel your pain
it was uh um it was making me think of a
Meetup we had before with Ryan at
Veterans Affairs on like going from this
100 multi I don't know how many hundreds
of pages PDF into a shiny app to really
like change the conversation with their
Executives being able to bring that
shiny app to to meetings I just put the
link in the chat if it's helpful for
anybody
um but Marlene I love a question you
asked in the chat a bit earlier and
would love to have you you jump in here
oh sure
um David Beau hi uh thanks for joining
us and um I'm Marlene hankin I'm over
here on the West Coast of studying of
the US Southern California
um I usually ask the aspirational
questions in the hangout so I'm gonna do
that again here especially with all the
great conversations happening in the
shiny conference um incredibly
inspirational for people who feel like
middle of the road getting the hang
um but I wanted to ask you know do you
have any
um like personal aspirations when it
comes to using our
um versus I'm sure you have corporate
goals right
um but like what do you want to do on a
personal level with with your R and
shiny Journey
I want everyone to use good
so they won't send code to me I know
attachment
I don't blame you yeah it's not specific
to r or
any language but I I think it would make
my life much easier
how about you David
uh yeah if I think about the
house studio
um Chinese have a pro migration
um I would say yeah that would be good
you know if everyone can use Version
Control git because sometimes I had to
to look for some code application which
was not even on git so we exchanged The
Code by email and I had to deploy the
application on the
connect which was uh if you imagine
there are like six seven applications
um yeah it's it's a bit challenging
um
and then yeah it's not only git but also
package dependencies with RF you know
when you start your project and any
project that not only is Xenia but it
could be a magnum could be even a book
for instance when I wrote the book uh
like the outstanding Channel iBook I I
first saw photable RF you know freezing
the packages I was using because I knew
at some point I would install a version
which would break everything
when it happens and I was able to
recover because because of that
and yeah that can really make your life
easier that's also makes your life
easier in cicd when you use RM you can
use a rambler to restore packages
seamlessly and then
works better with positive connect as
well so yeah it's all benefits
great thank you both for sharing
thank you for all these great questions
too
um something I I wanted to ask sometimes
we asked this towards the very end but I
want to put it in here because Marlene
you reminded me I love getting some of
these more like human-centric questions
too
um but David I'm curious what is the
best career advice you've ever received
or advice that you've given
and it doesn't have to be best maybe
just the first that comes to mind I
always to remind myself not to use the
word best there
uh that's tough one that's a tough one
uh that's not a technical uh advice I
gave uh that's just a mindset
advice probably like never give up right
it's hard today it will be better
tomorrow you know these kind of things
uh likely inside in the keynot I was
like I always go back to the keynote but
uh there are days you want to quit right
it's hard to make things work well using
best practices
but in the long run yeah you learn about
a lot about yourself
you collaborate better with people
um
but yeah I mean five reasons in life
it's um if you want to have like raise
your kids it's hard uh this part it hard
so that's like equipment point for
everything so believe in yourself and
never give up yeah
thank you
Omar I I see you have your hand raised
here do you want to jump in with your
question
yeah I wasn't sure what the proper
course no no that's great and thank you
I can put the reminder here because I
know we're coming in at different times
feel free to raise your hand on Zoom if
you want to ask questions you can also
use the slido link in the chat to ask
anonymously and then can also just put
them in Zoom chat too so thanks thanks
Omar sure no thank you uh so David
you're talking a little bit about the uh
RF and using uh connect for cicd sort of
deployments so the one thing with
connect is it's it's a pull so it pulls
from you could you could pull from um
it's designed to pull things in uh
sometimes that's different from a
Enterprise sort of scenario where you
have to they're expecting everything to
be packaged up and sent to the server
instead did you use orange to perhaps
address some of those challenges around
that
um just curious
yeah so for instance when we have
um like Australia for instance we want
to send to positive connect
so first of all we make sure it's using
RM right we have Frozen dependencies
then we have the cicd pipeline we have a
specific section in the ml file which is
restoring packages uh in the in the
runner and then
you have some instructions to deploy the
app on opposite connect so you need like
to use the collect API so yeah you you
need the API key on the different things
not going to enter too much into details
so
Project Connect doesn't use RN you know
when it restarts the application it uses
background but if you have Frozen
dependencies in the runner it's much
much easier than if there are packages
you don't even know where they are
coming from and you try to really push
everything and then you have error
messages everywhere on the Google
disconnect so
yeah from time to time it's
you still have problems right but there
are significantly reduced
great thank you so much for that
thank you see a few hands raise
um Eric I know you had a question
earlier in the chat too you want to jump
in
yeah I just saw the Fourier of activity
I was pretty it was going to get lost
but um first um David didn't ask me to
do this but he did mention it he has
written this amazing book this if you
are doing anything intermediate or
complex or shiny you need this book
especially with someone like me who does
not have any design background
whatsoever or web development training
before getting into shiny it has been a
huge valuable resource for me so thank
you David for for writing that of course
um to my actual question
um
certainly we've seen in talks even at
the conference or in other venues that
we're seeing shiny used in more places
in the pharmaceutical you know area of
development that's what Beau was saying
with DMC interactions so I guess in your
opinion what do you think are the
biggest hurdles for those that maybe are
coming new to Pharma but also new to
shiny for learning kind of the best
techniques to develop an application
that's effective especially with the
nuances and situations that we encounter
and Pharma quite a bit let's curious
your take on that
um it's not like the flow uh outside
China it's not just shiny but it's a way
you would learn Chinese when I learned
at the beginning I really learned
reactivity I learned at using reactive
using bookstore obser event isolate
but I didn't learn about RF I learned
later when I did the mistakes putting
everything to shania.io to posit connect
having my deployment fading because I
didn't have the the right version or
whatever
um this is this kind of flow um so when
you you see Shiny it's really if you
ever did like PHP with mySQL you coupled
everything together it's not that easy
and when I discovered Chinese in 2012
you know at the end of the year
um
it was super easy to develop this
interactive application you know you you
do this you have this select input you
change the table or that just works in
five minutes
but that's a trap uh you know because
yeah in the long run you would have more
and more features and then in the end
you have stability code which is harder
and harder to maintain
so yeah there is no strong emphasis
around modules so if you if you looked
at Amity stock from yesterday
yeah modules should be one another like
the first concept you should when you
learn Chinese
I see Eric clapping to that too I've
been a fan of modules as he knows yes so
so many questions that we could probably
make
hang out longer in the future but I want
to make sure I get to some of the
anonymous questions too
um and I don't know if Bo or uh David
you want to answer this one and then
Mike I see your hands while I will
definitely call on you next but the
question was how are the data teams
structured among engineering and
analytics are they siled or integrated
in terms of the end-to-end project
workflow
Bo do you want to answer that one or
David who wants to take that you repeat
the question
so the question is how are the data
teams structured among engineering and
analytics at Novartis
are they siled or integrated in terms of
the end-to-end project workflow
I guess in a Pharma someone who's also
in the Pharma industry please correct me
if I'm not if I'm wrong
my understanding of the of a data
engineer's role does not really exist
normally in the Pharma setting
um we have armies of trial statisticians
who I guess Falls more under the
analytics side or our bigger team
actually our umbrella team is called
yeah someone typed statistical
programmer that's my assumption but I
didn't want to
make that call in case because I I've
never worked in an organization with a
team that's titled data engineers
but um
the if we're talking about people who
create the data curate the data based on
specifications validate the data and
pipe them down stream for data
scientists and um
statisticians to create analysis on yes
that team is mostly traditionally called
SAS programmer in in Pharma and they are
two different organizations
um there are different ways of
organizing the two teams in different
Pharma companies sometimes they're in
completely different
branches of the company with different
set of hire management so basically
sometimes
um
the head of
the level of of communication between
stats programming and stats
and statistics
which mirrors to data engineers and data
scientists or data analysts
in a general term sometimes it happens
way up in the structure
sometimes kind of in the middle they're
merged together into a bigger
organization but on a day-to-day basis
in every project in every clinical
project you would have an assigned
programmer who's the engineer who
creates the data
and the statistician assigned to each
study even though they're like
management and management structure
they're in different teams with
reporting to different
um managers but the two functions always
work together on a clinical project
thanks well I I think there's a lot of
thoughts shared here in the chat too I
wondered if um if sep you wanted to jump
into with your perspective
no just it was a minor minor ad there's
all sorts of Pharma companies at all
kinds of levels that all kind of do
different things I'm sure from Novartis
to smaller companies is different so
yeah
and Eric I know you mentioned what you
call it at Eli Lilly too do you want to
jump in
yeah it's basically even though I don't
quite agree with the term they call that
the data Sciences group but not the
typical data science that you and I or
many in this call would expect but
they're the ones handling the day-to-day
of getting the data delivered correctly
or queries are answered and they have
their personnel embedded into like the
trial team or the study team so that
each trial gets one of their
representatives along of course stats
and programming and medical and all that
so they're they're pretty seamless in
the trial process I definitely don't
interact with them as much from like a
capability perspective but certainly and
from a day-to-day trial perspective
they're a huge part of it
well thank you Mike I see you have your
hand raised want to jump in
hi yeah I mean this is this is going to
be a softball question for David and boo
but I'm super impressed by what's
happening at Novartis where you've built
essentially the the data science team
have built these Lego bricks for in
modules for building shiny apps but then
other people who want to build shiny
apps aren't starting from a blank sheet
but they're kind of reusing those Lego
pieces do you want to talk us through
that because I I think that's uh a novel
approach
oh someone's getting someone's getting
uh their doorbell right wrong
you know it's like
um
so Mike when you say about the legal
pieces are you talking about
um
data pipeline presentation from
um yeah we had some presentation at our
in Pharma some years ago
uh where yeah there are some modules to
like develop visualization for clinical
trials
and then you can combine with modules
together to create your application so
you don't need to you know develop them
yourself
and that's basically
um yeah the the modules we I don't know
about how many modules we have but we
probably have like 30 32 modules
which you can basically plug into your
app and then depending what you want to
do if you want to do like safety
Explorer
um yeah
patient profile whatever
but yeah they're very still this issue
where you have application with very
specific needs
uh and in that case people need to dive
in the cloud and at some point that's
unavoidable but
um
yeah for for sure that's uh
a big change for us
and the main challenge is also like
making rules modules following best
practices in terms of like software
development using RNs uh everything you
know with the package and
thcd yeah
we are the team you know we are not even
10 in our team
so that's uh that's a lot on our
shoulders
yeah as Colleen said before you know
from time to time you you hear people
they are not super satisfied
um
yeah because PHP is not doing by what
it's an intended but in the meantime you
also have people that are really
thankful to to what you are doing so
that's also
rewilding as a developer
you can jump on this pool
we have a we have a bunch of of
questions so if it's okay if I kind of
Rapid Fire go through a few of them here
but
um another one on slido was
uh my group is using BS for Dash and
shiny pretty extensively and I really
love it
um the biggest frustration that they
this person runs into is if they want to
put in custom CSS and David they're
wondering if you have any advice
um
it depends what uh what they want to
achieve but yeah for if they want to
have custom CSS and yes for dash they
won't be able to use BSC
because be asleep bs4 Dash actually uses
uh like a refactored version of
bootstrap specific key bootstrap bar so
if you ever use put thread clip you
won't have the same variables the same
size viable so it won't work
um
so if you want to develop some something
for the long run I would say you may
want to go
changing SAS uh the suspect so when I
say sassy it's not uh SAS as a
statistician it's it says synthetically
or some steel sheets right that's uh
another
language
um so yeah there is a bit of learning
curve but in the long run you better
organize your style in the in the app
and that's yeah the best practice to
grow if it's just like
10 lines of CSS you may not want to use
says so it really depends
um how many we want to customize
I love the there's another question I
think it was from Damien if you're still
on on interacting with users do you want
to ask that
yeah sure hi everyone my name is Damian
I'm the president of Epsilon I'm really
happy to be here and really enjoying the
conference so far right now I'm in
Bulgaria but I'm actually on vacation so
I just came back from India in Vietnam
Vietnam so really enjoying the remote
setup and I wanted to ask you about the
users because the beauty of Chinese that
we can build apps like very fast in
small iterations and we can keep getting
the feedback and upgrading on them and
this makes it a like a bleeding edge
kind of software that we can provide to
the users and and I know that you're
also sure that it is not that easy to
get feedback from the users directly so
I wanted to hear a little bit more about
it how do you cope with this
so yeah just to know whether your
application are properly used uh whether
you know these kind of things right
and how people are using the
applications typically
um
so this is I'll be honest this is
something we will start to do at
Novartis
so I did it
um like in your pencils but I'm really
talking what we are doing at properties
um so what we have we have a Tracker in
positive connect which basically it's an
application I developed last year
and when I was in Japan so you know when
you travel you can have you can do many
things
and yeah this basically queries the API
to get like all applications for all
applications you get who is accessing
the application how much time which
basically gives you some insight uh
issue on uh like if you develop an
application for several teams you can
have some insight of what which team is
using the most this application and how
you could Target your support like if
you see one team is using the
application 20 times more than another
one
maybe you want to like invest more
people to provide cheap parts here
um and so this is like a global solution
that you can apply to all applications
that are deployed and that's not
something you need to add to the
application and that that's important
that's something that works
automatically as soon as the app is on
the server
and on the other side if you wanna know
how people are using the app so like the
in-app usage
um you may know
um like shiny head map let's study from
an experiment I I made around 8map.js my
script Library
because in the past I was using ajar to
track usage on my website
and one day I I yeah I was just
wondering why why shouldn't I I just use
shiny head map sorry I will choose a jar
on my Shelly apps so I tried the
tracking code to put it in the shiny app
and then I couldn't see anything
it didn't work and I contacted the shoe
parts and they told me yes it won't work
with any because that's quite specific
technology
um and then I I took the head map.js and
brought some very simple code with r and
JavaScript put it in a package and there
are released the shading head map so
basically each time you click in your
app it will record the X and Y location
and then aggregate the data at the end
of the day so you can see where people
are clicking that for instance you can
identify some dead zones in the
application
which will help you to refactor the
design at some point you know if you if
you realize there is a path that nobody
visits maybe that's because it's badly
designed or because you know for
whatever reason yeah so that's
essentially
what we would like to bring
and there is also user feedback like
sending Communications to users
so this one is a bit more active and you
can be frustrated because sometimes you
know you don't get the answer people are
very busy and then
yeah
I know we are quickly coming to the end
of our hour here unfortunately
um so our positive team is talking
behind the scenes that there's so many
awesome questions here that we will
think about how we can gather any
questions that didn't get answered and
maybe
think about a blog post or some other
resource so I just wanted to let
everybody know that in case your your
questions didn't get answered there's so
many great ones
um Niels I see you had asked something
in the chat I think around using apis in
addition to shiny do you want to jump in
and ask that
yes here
um yes I was wondering especially for
bigger applications
um if you want to separate Surfer from
Club from client side rendering maybe at
using
um
react as a front end and then separate
it from the back end using plumber API
it might be easier is that something you
do as well or you only appear in you
shine
from Clinical from App supporting
clinical projects it's an easier answer
is that we don't use anything beside
Chinese right now because first we don't
really have super big apps super
complicated app and super big
um
sample size
um clinical trial data are quite small
compared to many other Industries and
second is we actually tried react before
separating
the front end and back end just to
improve flexibility and the visual
effect and make it look better but
eventually like I said in the comments
um our team is very small like David
like David mentioned uh we're not our
goal is not to write a tool and maintain
a tool for each study that comes to us
but to create something that we can ship
off to our statisticians to use on their
own and to manage on their own and we
have much much better adoption of R
especially with the younger version of a
younger generation of statisticians
coming in from Academia
um many of them are quite fluent in R
um but I think we haven't
made the pivot in well I don't think
it's necessary for um trial
statisticians R is still the
um one of the best languages that they
are the most familiar with coming
in from nicotemia so
for some other bigger scale apps like
the one that David worked on for the HR
data or the POS Maybe
you're right Boo
um I I totally agree
um
we decided to go for R uh I'll leave
tomorrow we say people yeah we have to
go to Julia or whatever
at some point you know there'll be a big
class R is doing what we want to do with
swing it well now we have many tools if
we own a speed up training apps we use
parallel packages to to speed up
computations
um if we start to develop something with
react
the problem is we are like three in the
team to know react so if we leave in the
future then who is going to maintain the
tool
so if we develop it in R maybe it's not
as fast maybe it's not as optimized but
at least we can find someone to maintain
it in the future
and this is what matters you know when
you are in the industry at some point
okay maybe a quick uh like 10 second
answer from you David and Bo for for
teens who are just starting to like
learn how to use shiny uh or maybe
helping somebody else learn what is one
of your favorite resources
David you want to go first
uh hey sorry I had to cut I couldn't
hear at the end
okay Bo do you want to go uh first what
is one of your favorite resources for
learning shiny or something you'd
recommend
for me personally
stack overflow
um but for someone who's just starting
off I think a lot of the the gallery and
the and the tutorials on posit's website
um are there as I understand like
they're current there are news articles
um but you can always go back go back to
the I think there's a series of what 15
20 videos
um
um of shiny tutorials from the very
beginning
um I found that to be really helpful
yeah later patley's mastering shiny I
believe it's in it's on version two
right now
only a couple years ago thank you all
for sharing the links in the chat too as
we go that's so helpful
um and I know Maya you just mentioned R
for DS Community to help answer
questions too and that's an amazing
suggestion as well if we want to share
the link for how people can join that
Community too that would be really cool
awesome well I know we are coming to the
end of the time here and I don't want
anybody to be late for the next uh next
event and I do just want to remind
people that you'll go back to the shiny
conference page and use hop in to get to
the next event but if you had fun today
and and want to join us again we do have
these data science Hangouts every
Thursday from 12 to 1 eastern time so
the same time in the same place
um and so I'm just going to put this
link
into the chat if you wanted to add it to
your calendar you can do so there
there's also a data science hangout site
on the closet site that you can check
out recordings of past sessions as well
um with everybody here I just have to
also put a little plug here that the
call for speakers is open for the posit
conference in September in Chicago as
well so I just wanted to share that blog
post uh announcing that too but thank
you so much David and Bo for joining us
and answering everyone's questions thank
you all for jumping over here into the
hangout it's been fun spending time with
you and seeing all the great discussions
in the chat not able to follow along
with everything as we go so I'm looking
forward to reading it after as well
thank you everybody